in movies like carry blood comes by the
buckets perfecting that red gooey mess
took a long time and several different
recipes this is the story of how fake
movie blood is made
[Music]
back before film and TV a simple red
handkerchief on stage symbolized blood
but it was kind of boring so some
theatres up the ante by boiling a bug
known for its red pigment they used the
Cochin you bug because it creates red
dye when black and white movies came
along pigment in a matter so Hollywood
simplified things by using chocolate
syrup then in the 1930s when black and
white movies turned to color Hollywood
needed a new blood trick enter John Tyne
Gate a retired pharmacist living in
England he concocted the most realistic
looking blood yet called Kensington gore
using a combination of mostly golden
syrup food coloring cornflour and water
the most famous of the blood recipes
though comes from a man named dick Smith
he came up with something on par with a
Julia Child recipe the catch his recipe
was poisonous one ingredient Kodak photo
flow is deadly when consumed so people
started replacing the poison with
creamer and other items that won't kill
you today a lot of the fake blood you
see on screen is computer-generated but
if you want to be legit it should be
poison or bugs
you
you